dude but what is with the revision where
where do you fall on forrest gump i know
a lot of people
now hate it really so there's a lot of
there's
been hanging out with isis there's
there's big backlash and going back and
saying
what if you look what group are you
hanging out i don't agree with
you every tuesday
i don't agree with you but there are
some people who go have gone back now
and said forrest gump
not a good move get the [ __ ] out thank
you
trump is fantastic so i was on a date
with a girl in that movie
and dude there was a point in the movie
where i was tearing up right
and this was our second date and uh i
was about to lean over and go
it's a great movie right and she leans
over
and she goes are you crying
and i was like what she goes are you
[ __ ] crying
the jenny part she goes are you [ __ ]
crying at this movie and i was like
yeah and she was like you shouldn't be
just like that and i was like
dude first of all another movie jenny
real [ __ ] man
anything about jenny the [ __ ] she drug
my boy force gump through
just a real cocktail the entire time he
was loyal
then she gets aids dude yeah but i mean
and then finally she does this whole
[ __ ] she's whoring out
she's playing guitar on the road he
sticks by her she's with that black
panther dude yeah force beats his ass
he's ride or die then finally she's
[ __ ] every guy in alabama
gets done she goes you know what now
i'll be with you yeah
oh after he's a billionaire started
apple yeah man but just i don't know
she's a whole lot of an [ __ ] man i
know a lot of
young hot women who are gonna be dating
[ __ ] guys
what's he what that's the argument no
one knows what he has there's a thing on
the instagram they
not on instagram the web like they're
like what did forskoun have and they've
had
experts look at it it's asperger's that
makes sense
i but i also don't know a whole lot i'd
love to see him on uh
full spectrum uh yeah i don't know a
whole lot of young women who are dating
just being honest they're not they're
not going all in on asperger's bro
i'll tell you right now early on bill
gates or homeboy who owns amazon yes had
asperger's
yes they're still getting their dick
sucked yeah every day but look he
finally got jedi
when he had a little doe jenny was a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
hey look and i'll tell you something
else young robin wright oh my god
oh smoke show uncomfortably
google that what did forrest gump have
i'm pretty sure asperger's is probably
right also he uh he has 92 credits as an
actor
thomas tommy comics yeah he had a
40-something producer
thomas thomas tommy tommy how do you
feel about his son in the jamaican
accent
not mad at it makes me laugh if your
dad's force camp it's gonna be a tough
world to navigate yeah it really is yeah
you're gonna be a white rapper you know
who else is white rapper
tommy hilfiger's son really and it's
tied up all over his face how are your
bars
if i was like not good could you spin no
not at all
you know it's uh it's like something
like you like you have
yeah like you know like little dickie or
you know
these guys they just have it i don't
have that what would you say
on a one zero to ten if i was going to
be like your
freestyle zero zero are you a zero zero
i'm good with rhyming i can get four
lines out and then my brain goes that's
for me
gump talk i'm seeing autism i will tell
us with autism yeah
that but but autism is is uh isn't that
aren't autism asperger's
it's a spectrum it's in the spec on the
spectrum right
so i think they are
i but i think you know the more i
shows and the more i look into autism
and asperger's i think there are more
people i
know who might not have been diagnosed
you know when you saw love on the
spectrum buddies with some ass burgers
feel very aspergy or asperger who does
there are some people that both you and
i know yeah no i i got a buddy who he's
so ridiculously smart
yeah within his like connection verbal
skills like what the [ __ ] dude
yeah but you ask him like something
about history or this and he just
rattles off but as far as like so
personal
socially it's like a nightmare yeah when
you're like did you just say that out
loud in front of
everybody right now but they're really
good at this
one thing yeah you know they're really
smart in this area
i i am i think that that
telling the truth in public like that
without being diagnosed has got to be
really
really difficult like because people
what should i do
like have a card no but like before we
have a drink i want you to know
but you should say some [ __ ]
no but that's what i mean but like how
difficult must that be i can't even
imagine dude i can't imagine not being
diagnosed that's what i mean and you
think that there's something
wrong but i have a friend who's uh like
doesn't [ __ ] at all
yeah he's like always super truthful
even it hurts people's feelings
and i'm always scared to bring people
around him yeah
i'm like dude i'm telling you dude like
you [ __ ] you ain't called out on it
it's like
[ __ ] dude but if you can't you don't
feel like safe to play that's what i'm
saying 100
but if he had a so you find yourself
almost acting different like reserved
because you don't want the backlash to
come on you that makes sense oh that
means they have a friend who's like that
and you're like oh god better watch my
p's and q's or
well dude there's also like
man you know they're a guy i have guys
that i grew up with
that that's their whole game they just
can't wait for you to say something
stupid oh that's my brother
they're gonna ride you for a [ __ ]
hour that's my brother
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just read a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son